dodgeball on trampolines and asparagus
pile is a great way to hide a cake
Vsauce Kevin here this is mind blow this
stainless steel mechanical ring clock is
a concept that tells the time down to
the second with the current time being
highlighted along the individually
rotating rings and it will probably fit
well on this Bionic hand Matthew James
sent a letter asking for a new hand and
Mercedes said okay it has two electrodes
inside the socket that detect electrical
impulses made by the muscles of his
lower arm the signals are then beamed to
a mini computer in the palm which
translates the messages into movements
the movements of this robot head are
dependent upon the music that it reads
the cameras in the eyes read sheet music
that an algorithm translates the pitch
and the vocalizer sings it like this
electronics and human skin collide with
these skin patches designed to monitor
vital signs without invasive wires it
physically connects you to the cyber
world in a way that feels natural and
comfortable almost like a temporary
tattoo the eye tabulous is a 40 inch
display converted into a giant iPhone
just in case you ever wanted a coffee
table that plays Angry Birds what your
eyeballs to sparkle just wear diamond
contact lenses 18 diamonds are studded
in a circular manner on an 18 karat gold
device attached to the back of the
lenses that does not touch the cornea
and costs around $16,000 a pair old man
brushing his beard with a fork on the
subway this prize-winning 3d system is
built with a four sided glass enclosure
which displays the four sides of the
object it scans the object on a
turntable it reproduces it with four
projectors so you can physically walk
around it and see all sides now for the
ballet of the bulbs
finally here's a video game dance party
called what your games do behind your
back I'm gonna leave you with a riddle
my life can be measured in hours I serve
by being devoured thin I am quick fat I
am slow wind is my foe what am i there
are eight video game references in this
video the first person to name them all
will be our genius of the week so good
luck and as always thanks for watching
you